Another day,
another 10th blog,
coffee on a Tuesday and Vlog 50.
In vlog 48,
I talked about reality,
how growing up it seemed to me that much
of our social arrangements,
our convention,
less rules than communal guidelines only
as strong as the community makes them
and since the community is nothing but
people its rules,
its reality is as malleable as fluid as
we are in Vlog 49 without saying so
challenge that premise somewhat by
asking whether or not you should give
money to panhandlers.
Now,
it would be silly to think that by
asking such a question,
I was trying to get at the incidental
convention of my given community at my
given time,
even if that type of answer is the most
forthcoming,
I was trying to uncover a deeper rule,
a rule applicable to all circumstances
and all times I was trying to suss out
the older and wiser sister of
convention.
It's partner in the social universe.
The moral role.
Today I'd like to complete this trilogy
of videos and complete this line of
thinking about morality as best I can.
Morality is about art.
It's about what we ought to do when
formulating a moral rule.
We're not saying what we should do in
order for this or that to happen.
We have to be confident that what we say
is applicable to all people.
As a general rule.
For example,
let's say your friend tells you that
they just got a new haircut.
They love it,
but they want to know what you think.
Well,
you may think it looks bad,
but you say that it doesn't because you
don't want to hurt their field.
Now the moral rule isn't.
Don't tell jerry his bulk cut looks like
shit because he's got a thin skin.
Clearly that applies only to Jerry.
The moral role might be worded.
Don't make people feel sad.
If you can help them,
maybe you think it's right to tell Jerry
that his haircut,
his unflattering,
you value the truth.
Even if it hurts another legitimate
moral rule.
Always be honest.
You can see that morality is about right
with a capital r and wrong with a
capital w,
and of course people can disagree on
that like Jerry's two types of friends,
but that's a pretty innocuous example.
Here's another from Jonathan hates the
righteous mind.
Decide whether the people in this story
have done something morally wrong,
so a family has a dog named spot that
they love.
They've lived with them for many years.
One day spot is tragically killed by a
car in front of the families.
The family having heard that dog meat is
delicious.
Cut Up spots,
body cook it and eat him for dinner.
Nobody sees them do this.
So what do you think as hate explains
what you're probably feeling is disgust.
You want to say that this family has
done something wrong,
but then you remember it's their dog who
was already dead,
so they didn't hurt it and nobody saw
them,
so nobody was offended.
Maybe in the end you decide that what
the family did was disgusting.
Something that you would never dream of
doing,
but morally wrong.
Well,
you have to say no if that's your
answer.
If that's the way you feel,
you're most likely from the west and
you're most likely eliminate your
morality boils down more or less to what
the utilitarian genius John Stuart Mill
wrote in his essay on liberty,
what most western governments are based
on.
The only purpose for which power can be
rightly exercised over any member of a
civilized community against his will is
to prevent harm to others.
In other words,
maybe they're not people you'd want to
be friends with,
but it's their dog.
They're eating it.
Nobody was hurt,
so leave them alone.
Now,
if on the other hand,
you hear the story and you still say,
yes,
this is morally wrong than you are
working off another axis of morality,
and to understand it,
we have to look closer at what Haidt
calls moral foundations theory,
the six axes of morality mixed and
matched in different peoples around the
world.
First,
we have care harm what we've essentially
already covered and what makes up most
of the Western liberal morality.
Making sure that nobody is hurt unless
they're trying to hurt others and that
everyone is properly cared for.
Second,
you have fairness.
Cheating,
something that will also be familiar to
us,
we believe that people should read a
proportional share of what they saw and
we despise those who try to get more for
less work.
Third,
loyalty,
betrayal,
what makes us feel pride for our groups,
whether they be sports teams or
political parties or nations,
and what makes us feel rage against
those who are traders to fourth
authority.
Subversion,
which highlights the feeling that we
need leaders and that we fall into some
manmade or natural hierarchies like a
family or a corporation.
Navigating this moral terrain means
respecting your superiors while gaining
the respect from those below you so that
you can move up and down the social
ladder without triggering.
Number five,
liberty,
oppression.
We have a sense of when vulnerable
groups are being exploited or when our
liberties are being infringed upon,
say by a tyrant.
This can be interpreted differently
based on what your political leanings
and finally,
number six,
sanctity degradation,
what may cause us to feel that yes,
eating your own dog is morally wrong.
There are higher and lower ways of
light.
This foundation holds like a spectrum
stretching from lowly degenerates to
pure soul.
The Western liberal morality,
as I said,
leans heavily on the care harm
foundation with a little bit of
fairness.
Cheating and liberty oppression thrown
in.
Liberals don't care so much about the
other three.
In fact,
they may rail against them as immoral,
but ours is not the only morality in the
world.
Many cultures,
in fact,
most cultures,
some in our own country put a lot of
their stock in sanctity degradation,
for example,
especially religious culture.
The Bible and other sacred texts are
filled with rules on how you're supposed
to act to align yourself with God.
For what reason should the Bible teach
abstinence or the Torah forbid poor.
If not that chastity is considered godly
and pork is considered unclean and
impure.
These are just a couple of the modern
manifestations of sanctity degradation
and like authority,
subversion and loyalty,
betrayal.
They are felt more strongly in cultures
where the community is the central unit,
not the individual.
This is why patriarchal societies exist,
in which there are roles for women that
would make feminist gas,
but in which those women don't speak out
because they see the family as more
important than themselves.
All of these are real moralities and
each foundation is the product of
millions of years of evolution.
They were naturally selected to overcome
certain adaptive challenges like caring
for one's children or forming cohesive
coalitions or avoiding contaminants.
Of course,
the modern triggers for these
foundations can be very different from
the original ones.
100,000
years ago,
staying pure meant staying clean to
avoid infection,
passing on animal meat that was rotten
or poisonous.
Today it finds expression in virtue and
vice as they say,
cleanliness is next to godliness.
The essential point is that morality,
a product of evolution functions on more
axes than simply the golden rule.
That's a descriptive fact about humans
and understanding all six foundations
will help you not to immediately brush
off as stupid or evil.
Those who think differently than you.
It's not to say to be clear that all
moralities and all moral foundations are
equally good,
but deciding what combination is best
for society is the work of another field
called normative ethics.
It's work.
I'm afraid that I ought to leave up to
you.
Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for sticking with me
for 50 blogs.
I can't believe we've done that many.
I think the nerd writer has transformed
a lot since the beginning.
You know,
this is not a vlog about factoids or
just learning stuff.
It's a flag about building worldview.
That's what the experiment of the nerd
writer is and I don't mean for you to
take my worldview and that's what these
videos are.
It's to see how you can build one for
yourself.
If you want to watch parts one and two
of the morality trilogy,
you can find them here.
Also,
don't forget to follow me on tumbler and
twitter links in the description.
I hope you stay with me for another 50
blogs.
I'm excited to talk about more
interesting,
more complex,
more subtle stuff.
Thanks.